we've got a question for you Disney
Princesses what kind of a princess are
you what time do you have magic hair no
magic hands no what's it like having so
many rules to follow sure you're royalty
but that doesn't mean you're in charge
there are certain things everyone
expects from you and you got to be sure
you toe the line don't like animals
can't seem a tonight when all the world
is sleeping I'm going to struggle to
earn your place in the official lineup
we certainly got an insight into
princess rules when you met vanellope
and wreck-it Ralph too we loved hearing
you dish on what you have to do to keep
your Disney Princess status do you want
to know which strict rules the Disney
Princesses have to follow check out tens
right here and keep watching to discover
the one rule we think everyone should
obey be friends with animals if there's
one thing every Disney princess has in
common it's a lovable and dedicated set
of animal friends snow-white set the bar
high being able to speak to her forest
friends Cinderella has mice friends
Cinderella also pointed out how
important this rule is when she asked
Penelope do animals talk to you jasmine
has Raja the Tiger Mulan has moo shu the
dragon and creaky the cricket Rapunzel
hospice call the chameleon Merida has
Angus the horse Moana has puah the pig
and hay the rooster tiana had Lewis
Andrade the Firefly in fact Tiana took
it to a whole new level transforming
into an animal herself enjoy singing if
you can't sing you're going to find it
difficult to live up to the expectations
of a Disney princess Snow White even
combines the singing role with the
animal friendship role by performing a
duet with a baby bird Merida is the only
princess that doesn't allow us with her
singing voice in lots of songs don't
work it makes sense that Disney
Princesses wouldn't have to hold down a
regular job after all that's the same
rule for most princesses in the real
world they all follow this rule except
Tiana
not one but two jobs when she's busy
saving up to buy her restaurant Mulan
also worked as a soldier but that wasn't
a regular job however the rest of the
ladies weren't employees have royal
links to be a Disney Princess
you need to have royal links in one of
three ways you can be born the daughter
of a king Sultan or chief or you can
marry into royalty
that's what Cinderella Belle and tiana
did or you can do a heroic deed that is
so pure it elevates your status to
Princess level which is how Mulan became
a royal obey your father just because
the Disney Princesses are given strict
rules to abide by doesn't mean they
always follow them and the rule to obey
your father's command is a prime example
of this particularly with the
Renaissance princesses this group of
ladies includes Ariel Belle Jasmine
Mulan and Pocahontas they all had
fathers who expected them to do as they
were told and they all defied their
fathers Jasmine shows how important this
role is in defining a business s when
she asks Penelope if she has daddy
issues do you have daddy issues miss
your mom many Disney Princesses don't
have mothers it's like an unwritten rule
that these ladies are motherless when
Penelope tells the princesses she
doesn't have a mom a whole group of them
replied neither do we
Aurora and Rapunzel were both raised by
women other than their moms Merida
missed her mom in human form after she
transformed into a bear there are a few
princesses that break this mold though
like Mulan
well Ana's mom is still around but she
loses her grandma and then there's Tiana
who does have to deal with parental loss
but in relation to her father have a
female enemy the Disney princess is sure
do have complex relationships with other
women and not just their missing moms
there was certainly a rule in the early
years that the Nemesis had to be female
Snow White had the Evil Queen Cinderella
had the wicked stepmother
an Aurora had Maleficent Ariel had
Ursula but this rule got looser as the
Renaissance era progressed where
Rapunzel brought the rule back with a
bang with Mother Gothel and you could
argue that Merida's enemy was her own
mother have a love interest
nearly every Disney princess has a love
interest so it's pretty much a rule that
they have to fall in love and the power
of that love has to be strong enough to
save their lives
this is explicitly the case for the
earliest princesses as Snow White points
out when she asks vanellope by rejecting
any kind of suitor Merida broke this
mold as she did with quite a few rules
wanna also want without a love interest
but she did have a big dude helping her
in the shape of Maui wait for a man to
save you there are certain rules that
apply to the earliest Disney Princesses
in particular but also resonate
throughout the franchise and a major one
is the million dollar question that
Rapunzel asks vanellope she says do
people assume all your problems got
solved because a big strong man showed
up the more recent princesses buck this
turn but it's pretty ingrained in the
franchise follow your dreams
our last entry is the most inspiring
rule that the Disney Princesses have to
follow each of them has to follow their
dreams whatever they may be it could be
love in the case of the Golden Age
princesses or adventure as it is for the
Renaissance princesses or building a
light for yourself like the modern
princesses commit themselves to
I am editor we believe that's a pretty
great rule to follow which princess is
your favorite let us know in the
comments thanks for watching make sure
to subscribe to the things for more
videos like this one and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up we'll
see you next time
[Music]